لذلك اسمحوا لي أن أكون واضحًا تمامًا، فإن المحادثات
والوساطة لمحاولة إطلاق سراح
الرهائن المدنيين وربما
تبادل الأسرى في هذه المرحلة لم
تنهار بشكل صحيح، لا أعتقد أنهم ما
زالوا مستمرين، ولا تزال فرقة العمل
تعمل على ذلك، وكما قلت،
أصبح الأمر كذلك  أكثر فأكثر صعوبة مع
التصعيد الحالي، هذا التصعيد
الذي يحدث الآن، كما تعلمون،
أحد أفظع التصعيدات التي
حدثت في المنطقة منذ
فترة طويلة حقًا يجعل الأمر بالتأكيد أكثر
صعوبة كما قلت على
الجانب اللوجستي منه  مجرد نقل الأشخاص أثناء عملية
التوغل والقصف المتزايد
ولكن أيضًا من
الجانب السياسي بالطبع، كما تعلمون، الوساطة لا
تعمل إلا عندما يكون لديك فترات قادمة في ظل
هذا النوع من الصراع هذا النوع من أه
المواجهة بين الجانبين
يصبح الأمر أكثر صعوبة لكنه لا يزال
مستمرًا  ولا يمكننا أن نستسلم أستطيع أن أقول
لكم أننا في الحقيقة لا نستطيع أن نتخلى عن هذا
من جميع الأطراف، لا أحد في المنطقة يستطيع أن
يتخلى عن هذا ويترك
الأمر أه للعسكريين
ليقرروا ما سيحدث في  المستقبل ماذا
يمكنكم أنتم مقدمي الخدمة فيما يتعلق
بتفاصيل هذه المحادثات بشكل جيد من الواضح
بيكي أنا لا أستطيع الخوض في تفاصيل
هذا لأن همنا الرئيسي الآن هو
إيصال الرهائن أه إلى
عائلاتهم والتأكد من
نجاح هذه الوساطة وذلك  سيكون من
الصعب جدًا كما تعلم أه الآن إذا
شاركنا الكثير من التفاصيل ولكن
كما سمعت اليوم من رئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو ومن أه المتحدث
باسم حماس أه نحن نتحدث عن
فكرة خروج المزيد من الرهائن نحن  عندما
نتحدث عن فكرة
تبادل الأسرى، فإننا متفائلون بأن القوات المسلحة
تتجه أكثر نحو جميع
الرهائن المدنيين ولكن من الواضح أن
الوضع مائع على الأرض، وما زلنا لا
نعرف ما سيحدث، هل نعرف
عدد الرهائن المدنيين المحتجزين هناك؟  في
غزة حاليا لست متأكدا من أن
أحدا يعرف الصراحة أه لدينا
أرقامنا التي نناقشها
تعرف من خلال القوائم التي نحصل عليها من
مختلف البلدان عن أه
المواطنين الأجانب المحتجزين كرهائن لدينا
الأرقام من  لدى الجانب الإسرائيلي
أرقام من جانب إيان الشاحب ولكن
هذه الأرقام ليست بالضرورة هي
نفسها دائمًا ولكن الشيء المهم
هنا هو أن كلا الجانبين يعترفان بأن
الرهائن المدنيين بحاجة إلى الخروج
على الفور وقد
قال كلا الجانبين، وخاصة حماس، في هذا الشأن  من
الواضح جدًا أنهم على استعداد للسماح
للرهائن المدنيين بالخروج، لذا
يتعين علينا أن نعمل على تحقيق ذلك في أقرب وقت
ممكن. ونحن نعلم أن حماس كانت
تضغط من أجل إطلاق سراح
النساء والمراهقات الفلسطينيين على الأقل المحتجزين في
السجون الإسرائيلية، كما سمعنا بنيامين ن.
أقول اليوم أنه تمت مناقشة ذلك
في مجلس الوزراء الحربي، هل يمكنني الضغط عليك بشأن
ما إذا كنت تعتقد أن هذا التبادل
يمكن أن يكون للنساء والأطفال
المحتجزين في غزة من قبل حماس، وإذا كان الأمر كذلك فإننا
نتحدث حول ما يقرب من 50 60 شخصًا هنا من
الواضح أه بيكي نحن  لقد تحدثنا
عن أولوياتنا في
هذا الأمر، فهدفنا الرئيسي وهدفنا النهائي هو
إطلاق سراح جميع الرهائن
وإعادتهم إلى عائلاتهم ولكن من
الواضح أنه عندما تضعه وعندما تحدده
كأولوية فإنك تبدأ بـ  النساء
والأطفال، تبدأ
بالأجانب والمدنيين ثم تذهب
إلى بقية الرهائن ومن
الواضح أننا إذا أردنا إعطاء الأولوية
فسنبدأ بالنساء
والأطفال ولكني أعتقد أن
المناقشات الآن  تشمل أنك تعرف
فكرة الرهائن المدنيين جميعًا